bonjour que désirez-vous trente ans de
métier passés derrière le comptoir d'un
bureau de tabac
la carrière de jean marais coignet a été
marquée par les vols alors pour se
protéger en bon connaisseur il a truffé
son magasin de caméras nous avons deux
caméras ce que j'ai dit l'allée centrale
l'autre qui fait cette caisse en tout il
en installer 17 dans son commerce un
bureau de tabac transformer en
bijouterie car jean marie a été
cambriolée ou braqué cette fois parfois
violemment
alors malgré les caméras la peur est
toujours présente
chaque fois que je fais un cambriolage à
ma chance je n'étais pas dans trois
semaines à moins bien sûr motivé pour
aller dans un endroit où on n'est pas
sûr parce que la journée soit bt si cela
fait presque deux ans que son magasin
n'a pas été attaquée en côte d'or les
vols se multiplient tabac boulangerie ou
magasins d'optique déjà six cambriolages
en 2018 alors que le département n'en
avait connue que 12 l'année passée il ya
incontestablement un phénomène qui est
liée à la hausse du prix du tabac
c'est vrai que maintenant les cartouches
de cigarettes ont une valeur marchande
et qu'elles peuvent ensuite être je
dirais revendus dans un marché parallèle
face à la recrudescence de ce type de
vol la gendarmerie a développé une
application mobile alert commerce
un nouveau moyen de mettre au courant
rapidement les gérants de magasins il
serait déjà 700 à l'avoir téléchargé